[Musique]
et on retrouve à présent nickel et demi
d'euros bonsoir bonsoir analystes sport
de la rédaction vous nous faites un
panorama des résultats sportifs du
week-end dans le département du football
pour commencer michael avec le
championnat de nationale 3 exactement
versailles à torcy c'était l'une des
affiches de cette sixième journée du
championnat de nationale 3 après une
première période équilibrée ponctuée par
un triste 0 à 0 les versailles et sont
plus entreprenants au retour des
vestiaires et arrive à trouver la faille
dans le dernier quart d'heure grâce à un
doublé de benjamin à louvain six fois
buteur en six matchs depuis le début de
la saison c'est pas mal un grégory
superbe le but grâce à yaya parachève sa
victoire grâce à johan akassou score
final 3 à 0 on écoute la réaction du
héros du jour a eu l'habitude que nous
de toujours bien commencé vraiment c'est
fort va réussir à marquer dès le début
j'en est tombé costumes vraiment une
bonne équipe bien en place
dans l'ain su être patient et
franchement sur la deuxième mi temps à
mettre un petit coup de folie pour
pouvoir accélérer on a eu un petit peu
de chance aussi pas se mentir mais ça
fait partie du jeu aussi avec six
victoires en six matches 17 buts marqués
1 seul but encaissé versées et réalise
un début de saison presque parfait des
résultats qui permettent aux joueurs de
la cité royale de faire cavalier seul en
tête avec déjà cinq points d'avancé sur
le paris fc on écoute l'entraîneur des
prix forcément parce que je vais pouvoir
enchaîner autant de matches en étant
solide en refusant la défaite nous c'est
que les choses se passent entre les
joueurs est l'état d'esprit le fait
d'avoir un objectif commun est de rester
une partition sur le terrain qui nous
permet d'avoir ce résultat prochain
match pour versailles ce dimanche 13
octobre sur le terrain de courcouronnes
en coupe de france
une victoire ce serait délicat comme
début de saison intègre et on va suivre
cette série voir si cette série se
poursuit on joue également toujours
c'est du football un mickaël le
championnat de régionale 2 on jouait une
journée de régionale 2 e acte trap a
signé ce week-end sa première victoire
de la saison les trappistes promu cette
année sont allés s'imposer sur le score
de 3 à 0 sur le terrain du causse modern
une victoire qui leur permet de remonter
au classement et de ne plus être
lanterne rouge il se retrouve à la 10e
place sur 12 on écoute l'entraîneur de
l'équipe
ludovic gotti mois de septembre
catastrophique on avait à coeur de
débuter le mois d'octobre par une
victoire
et voilà c'est chose faite j'espère que
ça va lancer bonne dynamique et et qu'on
va pouvoir enchaîner les bons résultats
sur les autres n'étaient pas encore
vraiment une équipe
accra pierre plein de bons joueurs
n'étaient pas une équipe
et hier on a été l'équipe solidaires
déterminés à gagner
on termine par du basket qu'elle trappe
se ressaisit dans ce championnat de
nationale 3 les trappistes se sont
imposés ce samedi soir sur leur terrain
contre like montivilliers 69 à 70 lors
de la 3e journée leur deuxième victoire
de la saison
un résultat qui leur permet d'être dans
le top 3 du championnat l'objectif du
club sera cette année à la montée après
l'avoir loupé de peu l'année
merci michael pour ce tour d'horizon on
vous retrouve dans un instant l'émission
7,8 sport sur tv 78 il sera question
notamment de marche nordique sa soeur
nordiques c'est ça un rendez vous qui
sera programmé à versailles ce week-end
ce dimanche il y aura également on
parlera également du rallye gazelle elle
mène c'est un rallye au maroc
vous verrez avec deux béliziens qui sens
dans l' aventure et plus d'informations
dans votre 7,8 sport à retrouver est
donc après ce journal sur tv 78 ans
michel allez vous échauffer